hey everyone this is Steve voncho with
collider and I'm here in our studio at
Sundance which is sponsored by Saratoga
Spring Water everyone knows the
importance of having a sponsor when it's
at Sundance it's expensive to be here
thank you Saratoga uh I am here with
everyone behind Onyx and I am really
happy you're here and I really say a
congratulations on pulling off this film
making it and being part of Sundance you
are one of those Kickstarter success
stories yeah thank you so much it's a
wild ride and we were just talking
earlier about how it just seems like
yesterday we were running that
Kickstarter and now we're sitting here
with you it's amazing so everyone
watching right now almost everyone
watching will not have seen the movie
yet so I hate doing the thing but how
have you been describing the film to
friends and family I've been saying it's
a it's an 80s throwback monster comedy
in the vein of Gremlins are fright night
but through a modern lens where Onyx
goes on a supernatural Adventure so for
people that don't realize you kind of
went viral on the internet playing this
character and doing newscasts but
getting on TV yeah and I kept on
wondering how uh how did you because not
only did you get on TV but you were
delivering like lines like you had to
give enough to the television station
that they would want to put you on
television so I'm just curious what was
it like how did you pull off be getting
you know getting on TV so often as Onyx
well this is this is quite a bomb to
drop uh I was never on TV well those are
all what I would do is I would rip News
videos and then film myself out in
Burbank and splice them together and
then release them as such but I was
never actually on TV but people thought
he was on but people so much so to wear
so much so hi you thought I was on TV
yeah
you were on TV well so much so to wear a
producer of one of those new segments on
a radio interview said I can't believe
we let you talk for that long and I
don't remember letting you on the air
and I said yeah you didn't it was a it
was a joke
um but yes they appear as if they're
real newscasts and that's how we kind of
floated on the internet over the years
okay first of all that's amazing and
second of all I totally got fooled and I
say congratulations because that's
awesome like I honestly so but for for
everybody uh one of the things this is
this is a movie I really enjoyed and I
really I can't believe what you were
able to put on screen with the budget
that you had like it's it's crazy just
because I know how movies are made so
for for all of you guys can you sort of
talk about what it was like being part
of a project like this where everyone is
clearly doing like double work you know
like you're carrying whatever you need
to carry in between scene you know what
I mean
I mean at a Velda project I've ever
worked on as an actor or producer this
was the most fun anyone's ever had on a
set and I think the vibe even from the
moment we met everybody everyone knew
this was something special that they
poured their hearts into so everyone on
set was willing to help every department
and know that everything should go on
screen we didn't have any debos or
anything like that everyone had so much
fun that I think it just really comes
through on the screen
it felt like summer camp I mean it was a
blast and and I think that every every
Department got to really show what they
could do whether it was as a performer
or the art department or costumes or
hair like everybody got to strut their
stuff and honestly it felt like a 30
million dollar movie it did not feel the
way it was run it was treated like a big
budget movie the the first ad was
incredible the crew was incredible there
was no part of it that felt remotely low
budget at all it was it I was blown I
mean it's to me a testament to Andrew
like he he everybody loves him it was it
starts at the top and like he's a star
he's the writer he's the editor he's the
director and like everybody wanted to do
a good job to help bring his vision to
life
well thank you I mean I I was so
fortunate to have department heads and
producers in this cast that that
supported the vision I mean everybody
put in a hundred and twenty percent
every single day even out overnight in
cemeteries with snow and rain everybody
showed up and impressed me every single
day
I don't we I wanted to know if either if
you wanted to add anything sure this was
the most respectful and calm working
environment I've ever had on any
production and that tone was set by
Andrew and everything just seemed to
work and every Department had a unified
vision and I think that's why it also
was very seamless I think to your point
of even you thought he was on he like I
really think he's a genius and I'm not
like I really I I did not know Andrew
before this and like like I have been
nothing but blown away and as a and he's
a graceful person he's a kind person and
like it's his vision without being
heavy-handed about it but like like
everybody it was truly like I really
think he's a very unique special talent
how much did you pay her to say that I
paying her in Saratoga I love Waters
gotta stay tight and fresh and hydrated
yeah no I Echo what everyone said it was
the most fun I've ever had on set for
sure and I just felt supported through
the whole process this was also like my
first time like as a non-binary person
playing a non-binary role in something
and I felt very respected on that level
too and it was just such an honor to
like watch the whole thing come together
I'm also curious again you didn't have
like Marvel money to make this but there
are some like creatures in this and
stuff like how the F did you pull this
off like no BS it really took uh finding
a special artist his name is Adam
Doherty and his shop is called creature
kid I'd been a fan of his for years from
going to monsterpalooza and horror
conventions all over the place I've even
bought toys from him and I reached out
to him to just do a character design for
one of the creatures and he read the
script and he said well Bales what if I
what if I did all of them and he was
really trying to launch his his new shop
as uh leading up his own shop for the
first time and so I lucked out that he
responded to the material and his
talents I mean they're just endless and
his whole team of puppeteers and
Fabricators they did something that I
don't think any of us thought they could
do with the time and the money that we
had yeah I'm sure you guys saw this
stuff on set and I mean were you like
you know is this a bigger budget movie
than I'm thinking it is because some of
the creatures looked like incred
incredible for the budget you had
yeah we really lucked out I mean Adam
and his whole team poured their whole
hearts into it and like through the
design process when we were looking at
the different iterations of the puppets
they just kept getting cooler and cooler
and cooler and then when we finally got
on set and saw them I mean our minds
were blown like it just didn't seem real
they are incredible and we're gonna have
some of them at the premiere I'm
actually going to switch when you were
making this I'm sure like did you even
think about Sundance as a possibility or
like when did and what is it like for
all of you guys to have this here at
Sundance
I still can't believe this is happening
to be here I thought we were literally
being punked when you told us that we
got into something yeah
I mean I guess you must think it's a
possibility because you submit so
somewhere in there is is a level of
optimism that drives you through
production and drives you to get the
film done in time to submit to an
amazing Festival like this but truly I
did not expect to get the call no no
that was mind-blowing there was he um
they revealed the news to us in a very
brilliant way so one Saturday Sunday
afternoon he got all of us together on a
zoom and said it was for like EPK asked
us some questions about the movie and
then he asked how did you guys feel when
you heard that Onyx is going to Sundance
yeah
when he told me he came my house to tell
me the night and found out and I didn't
believe him and I
pushed him across the street yeah
multiple times until he was into a fence
yeah hard yeah I just feel so proud like
again I I've said this before but it's
so as a you know as a creative person I
find it very inspiring to watch somebody
who's very much stayed true to his
vision and that to me like the biggest
independent film festival in the world
respond like like people see like if you
stay true and his heart is but like
there's been nothing but good vibes on
this and that that of course people are
like it just made me very proud it's
inspiring like that if you protect your
vision you protect your magic like the
world will respond and it's very
wonderful we just had the best time
making it uh I'm curious so you get in
the editing room you have all your
footage uh what what surprised you in
the editing room what changes did you
make that you were not expecting
I can say that because I'm also the
editor of the film I get a little
fixated on uh continuity I really switch
into editor brain mode and I stop
thinking about performance to a degree I
start I start uh getting a little lost
in the weeds and Olivia was was with me
in my garage while while I cut and I
think what I was surprised by was how
even if I cut something exactly how I
imagined cutting it it was important to
have a second set of eyes to say well
have you thought about I know you really
want to match the movement of the hand
in that scene but what about a different
take because of the performance yeah and
and so she helped me kind of step out of
my editor mode and yeah and rework
something based on pacing or performance
because I can get a little too binary in
my thinking when I'm when I'm in editor
mode I will say about the script I mean
Andrew writes the Titus scripts like
everything he ever writes I absolutely
love and everything that's in the script
is in the movie like nothing got moved
around nothing got changed we only cut
two scenes out of the whole thing but
you know he writes to the edit and then
directs to the edit and it's all there
and it makes for the editing process to
just be a really fun process because
you're not scrambling trying to find
things it was all there in the beginning
uh if you don't mind sharing how long
did you actually how many shooting days
did you actually have
we shot for about 20 in Massachusetts a
wonderful town called Lennox in the
Berkshires and then another five in Los
Angeles so about 25 days uh yeah for
people that don't realize that's not a
lot of time to make a movie you know
yeah especially with puppets involved I
was gonna say um I just have to say as a
fan of uh Jeffrey Combs I was very happy
to see him in this uh what was your
inspiration for casting him well I mean
I'm a huge Stuart Gordon fan reanimator
from Beyond and
um so I've always hoped to work with
both Barbara and Jeffrey at some point
but I actually think it was Barbara when
I told her about this project that
brought up Jeffrey and uh I just he
hadn't come to mind maybe because I knew
Bartok was bald with a long goatee and
and I was kind of basing him off of
hammer horror villains and then as soon
as she suggested him it it hit me and I
was like he's the guy he's the guy uh
one of the things about the film is it's
like about a found family you know and
so can you sort of talk about that
aspect of the film
well it was all about finding the
Ensemble I I I've told the story that I
started writing the script and I thought
maybe it would be a pretty gory horror
comedy where Onyx and a group of other
occultists were killed off one by one
and he was splattered in blood like
Bruce Campbell but I just I didn't have
the heart to do that uh when I started
writing these characters and I realized
it was more important and it was more
centered with the heart of the film to
give hanuk some friends and some
Companions and then once you know I met
these people and we got on set one of
the first scenes we did was a dinner
conversation between all of us and I
knew that it was the right Alchemy it
was the right move to have it be a group
effort going on this adventure and I
really loved shooting that day too
because it was our it was all of our
first day on set so we were like
actively getting to know each other
while the characters were getting to
know each other in the scene as well we
shot at this like Haunted Mansion if it
was it had extra juice you know it just
like it was for sure haunted we stayed
at what felt like a haunted in my room
for sure was haunted and but like that
made it fun I mean that added to the
element of like here we are out in the
mountains like in these very beautiful
beautiful interesting historic buildings
that are so haunted making a horror
movie it just it added to the it you
couldn't believe like you couldn't have
picked a better set
um I have a million other questions but
I need to wrap due to the constraints of
our time today but I look forward to
talking more specifically about the film
once people have seen it and you know
when you can actually get into it I just
want to say congrats thank you thank you
very much being part of Sundance uh and
I really hope it's a huge hit here thank
you so much thank you